hey guys snows here with Hardware
connects and you might not know this
about me but I'm the type of person who
gets more excited about budget stuff
rather than anything high-end I mean
give me that bang for the buck and I'm
happy and that's why I'm here talking
about the new RX 6500 XT it's a card
that I hoped would have been a perfect
fit for people who needed a new GPU and
just couldn't find one or for people
that can't afford the crazy markups that
are out there right now now notice I
said hoped well yeah that didn't happen
for a bunch of reasons but let's start
right at the top with the specifications
compared to its bigger brother the RX
6600 the 6500 XT got some major bits
chopped off but it's also more efficient
there's a lot less stream processors
only 16 megabytes of infinity cache and
while the memory speed gets a bump to 18
gbits per second there's only 4 GB on
tap here clock speeds do get a big bump
but it looks like the major issue is the
ridiculously narrow 64-bit memory
interface with just 144 GB per second of
bandwidth I mean AMD probably is hoping
that the infinity cache will take up
some of that slack but that's only going
to take you so far since a lot of games
these days are pretty bandwidth hungry
and when we look at its predecessor
there's a bit of a sticky situation
against the 5500 xt2 remember the 6500
XT is supposed to be replacing this
thing but the older card has more cores
a wider memory bus more bandwidth and it
came with either four or eight GB of uh
gddr6 memory so on paper it looks like
AMD is actually regressed in a bunch of
areas but before we talk performance
let's talk about launch prices because
of course there's a reason to complain
here too and that's because AMD is
pricing the 6500 XT the same as the 5500
XT 8 GB and a good $30 more than the 4
GB version of the now 2-year-old card
and of course $99 is the suggested
pricing all the board partners that we
talked about mentioned that it will
probably hit the store shelves between
250 and
$350 yikes oh and speaking of pricing I
guess now is a good time to pay some
bills so roll it how would you define
evolution perhaps constant Improvement
based on earlier iterations developing a
better product for the future going from
Big to small or simply building
something so feature packed I have no
time to cover everything I mean come on
leam this new case is incredible and
finally a proper tagline that absolutely
fits Evolution
continues the new 01 Dynamic Evo by lean
Lee you got to check it out
below so with that out of the way some
people think that AMD cut the balls off
of this card to make it less appealing
to miners but look if you really think
that AMD cares about selling less cards
I've got a bridge that I want to sell
you because to me the 6500 XT just feels
like a convenient excuse to push a
gimped GPU into the market that's
willing to buy pretty much anything
these days and speaking of pricing being
almost Irrelevant this is one time I'm
glad most board partners are taking a
bit of a break from their ridiculously
huge and stupidly expensive three fan
designs the vast majority of cars are
pretty compact with one or two fans
there are a few exceptions of course a
great example of good cooler design is
the card that I've got right here the
gigabyte Eagle I mean look at this thing
it's exactly what I'd want from a lower
priced GPU it's compact it's two slots
it uses a single six spin power
connector and it doesn't have all sorts
of flashy crap all over the place it
doesn't even have a back plate which I'm
perfectly fine with I just hope that
this hits 199 but that's about as likely
as a stormtrooper making an accurate
shot there's also a pretty big
limitation for all of you guys who might
want to use three monitors yeah you just
can't the 6500 XT only supports two
native display outputs that's it and
yeah it's less than the three or four
outputs found on most 5500 XTS I'm just
going to keep comparing them because it
makes no sense to me what the heck AMD
and that's not it either no it gets
worse because buried in the specs of
this thing is this while the 5500 XTS
media engine supported decoding and
encoding of h.264 and h.265 content
there's absolutely no video encoding
support here none nada zil oh and av1
decoding a feature that was added to
every other RX 6000 card yeah yep you
won't find it here what that means is
you can't use the video engine for
acceleration on streaming apps like OBS
for video editing or for simple
transcoding apps like handbrake the
option is completely gone even though
the older RX 5500 series had all of
these options except for the av1 support
for example that means NL like Adobe
Media encoder revert back to software
encoding while resolve Studio won't even
allow you to render a video using h.265
remember these additional capabilities
are a key selling point for every single
graphics card today and AMD disabling
them is just well a huge step backwards
basically it means renders that usually
take a few minutes to complete end up
taking a hell of a lot longer even on a
high-end system like on mine or in the
case of resolve you'll need to step back
to h.264 and still deal with longer
renders honestly not having the gpus en
coding engine backstopping mid-level
CPUs is going to be a huge loss for
anyone that wants to do creative work
with a 6500 XT on the positive side
though it doesn't affect open CL GPU
acceleration so you can still use it for
scene rendering and apps like blender in
those cases the rdna2 architecture
allows it to beat the rx580 but still
only match the RX 5500 XT oh yeah and it
also gets beaten like a pinata by the
3-year-old GTX 1660 something else that
I need to mention is amd's use of only
four PCI E Lanes on on this card on
paper at least there's more than enough
bandwidth when it's installed on a Gen 4
motherboard but a lot of people are
probably looking at the 6500 XT as a
simple drop in replacement for an older
GPU that was running on a gen 3
motherboard and does running it with
just four pcie Gen 4 Lanes cause a
bottleneck well the answer to that is
yes and no some games like Doom Jedi and
OverWatch aren't affected at all but
others man they're just taking it right
on the chin and see their frame rates
smashed downwards on a gen 3 interface
if you look a bit closer a lot of the
titles that are affected are a bit more
CPU bound and that's bad news since most
popular competitive Shooters and other
online games fall into that category I
really can't emphasize enough how bad
this is for the RX 6500 XT here you'd be
paying good money for this card as an
upgrade for an older system and
depending on the game it won't be
getting anywhere near the performance
AMD promised and at this point I just
say no thanks and walk away seriously
now with all of that out of the way
let's talk price to Performance I
already mentioned the RX 5500 XT and the
RX 6600 but remember that the rx580
launched at about the same price point
and check out those Nvidia cards man
those were the good old days when you
could buy some amazing performance for
about 200 bucks I mean the GTX 1660 is
still one of the most popular graphics
cards on the planet and as we go through
the performance charts it's obvious why
the 1660 is still so popular even now
almost 3 years after it launched for
just over 200 bucks it's still stays
ahead of the RX 6500 XT that's
especially true for games that rely a
bit more on memory bandwidth and doom is
a perfect example of that no amount of
infinity cash can save the cards in
those situations and it's not just the
Nvidia cards making the 6500 look bad
the RX 5500xt 4 GB is literally a carbon
copy right across Ross every single
Benchmark and if you take the cut down
features into account it's almost like
AMD regressed in the lower nend GPU
market and if you go a little further
back to Dr rx580 there's been almost no
forward progress at all it's like
they've been releasing gpus with the
same performance for the same price for
almost five damn years the other problem
is how the 6500 XT compares to the 6600
I mean you can drive a freaking truck
through the space between them the Gap
is huge looking at this it just feels
like the 6500 xt's performance has just
been gimped way too much but it's not
all bad the only thing that sort of
saves amd's bacon here is power
consumption since even though it's
running at ultra high frequencies here
the rdna2 architecture is still very
efficient but when it comes to gaming I
mean people care less about how much
electricity they're using and more about
the raw performance all right so I guess
that kind of wraps things up a bit here
and yeah this is another disappointment
and even if we take a step away from the
insane pricing situation that we have
right now with the shortage and all what
AMD has basically done here is
re-release the 5500 XT with about the
same performance and less features
they've proven what everyone has been
saying the lower-end GPU Market has
completely stagnated I mean the GTX 1660
came out almost 3 years ago and here we
are with a GPU launched at pretty much
the same price that doesn't get one iota
more performance in fact it's worse plus
unlike this thing every Nvidia card has
full encoding and decoding capabilities
and no the performance of R tracing is
not something that we should care about
in this market this whole situation has
become a really sad joke by this point
it's pretty much an insult for gamers
who've been waiting for a great budget
option for years now meanwhile all the
6500 XT proves is that there's no good
guys anymore just happy shareholders in
any case guys that's pretty much it for
today's video hopefully you've enjoyed
leave a like if you liked it a comment
if you want to discuss this a little
further I know a lot of you are going to
be vocal about this as usual you can
click right here to see the latest video
right here to subscribe to the channel
stay frosting my dudes and I'll see you
on the next one take care man the
comments are going to be really
interesting as a person who builds
computers for family and stuff like that
I don't judge what they're going to do
they could be gaming they could be doing
creative workloads I just want them to
have something that works and this is an
insult to me yeah see you